this is Startalk deplorable perception
that is probably not someone's real name
I am guessing that is a form of Ceuta
unless their parents were dyed by
diabolical and also unless they have
what is perception yeah thank you yeah
so here's his question I like that I'm
like it's a guy how will we solve the
looming question of energy storage
that's a great question I am all for the
liquid metal batteries these are
batteries that have magnesium floating
on a layer of molten salt essentially
table salt and at the bottom is a layer
of antimony or in timoney mm-hmm which
is the one that's atomic number 51 I
believe next to tin on the periodic
table and so you pour this is all
correct where's our fact checker so you
pump in energy and it gets hot and it's
molten and that works how long is a
battery in it how long does the storage
well as my understanding as long as it's
hot it's storing electricity so you'd
put these things in the basement of
every building in the basement of every
New York skyscraper of every school and
library you make an you produce
electricity with sunlight and so and
wind during the day you store it
underground you're ready for it all
night and we revolutionize society and
whoever goes into this business mm-hmm
gets there I say it rich it's an
opportunity for somebody if you could if
we could find ways to efficiently store
electricity better batteries yeah we
would change the world and make a much
higher quality of life for everybody so
we have to move on gentlemen
you